sur le plateau line rifai qui vient de
nous rejoindre on va passer de on va
parler de l'économie et les impacts sur
l'économie bonjour line l'annnonce du
président russe vladimir poutine d'une
opération militaire en ukraine a fait
réagir les marchés avec d'abord cette
nouvelle flambée du pétrole will flambée
du pétrole flambent et du gaz mais on va
vous regarder aussi ce qui se passe
d'abord sur la bourse europe 1 à
l'entrée la bourse et les marchés
européens qui vient justement d'ouvrir
après avoir suspendu ses cotations ce
matin la bourse de moscou a rouvert en
chute de 14% et puis la chute s'est
accentuée depuis pour atteindre 28%
environ en ce moment la monnaie russe a
aussi chuté de 9% jeudi matin et attend
un plus bas historique
conséquence la banque centrale russe a
réagi en lançant des interventions sur
le marché des changes pour stabiliser la
situation
et puis vous le voyez réaction aussi sur
les marchés financiers européens qui eux
viennent d'ouvrir avait en forte baisse
baisse de plus de 4% pour le cac 40 à
paris de plus de 4% également pour le
dax à francfort et quasiment 3% de
baisse en début de séance pour le
footsie à londres a tous sillage des
marchés asiatiques qui également ont
terminé la science ce matin en forte
baisse et là où il ya d'importantes
réactions c'est sur les marchés des
matières premières est d'abord le marché
du gaz le gaz non par les armes elle
tout à l'heure vous le voyez une flambée
du prix de gaz coté donc sur la bourse
aux pays-bas + 29 % en début de séance à
cause des craintes sur
l'approvisionnement européen en gaz
russe également conséquents sur le
pétrole le pétrole qui rebondit
fortement dépasse la barre symbolique
des 100 dollars une hausse de plus de 5%
le brent est désormais au dessus de 100
dollars le baril et le pétrole
le pétrole américains donc qui bondit au
site de plus de 5% enfin pour être
complet il faut aussi mentionner la
flambée des cours de ces des céréales
car l'ukraine et la russie sont parmi
les principaux producteurs et
exportateurs monde plus 5,1 pour cent
pour le maïs 5,6 pour cent pour le blé
et s'il ya un tel impact des annonces du
président russe sur les marchés de
matières premières et notamment du blé
c'est aussi parce que l'ukraine est l'un
des principaux producteurs de céréales
dans le monde en effet c'est vrai
l'ukraine est d'abord l'un des
principaux producteurs de céréales au
monde grâce à ses immenses surfaces de
terres arables elles représentent 55% de
l'ensemble des terres le pays fournit 12
% de l'offre mondiale de blé et 16 % de
l'offre mondiale de maïs il produit
aussi exporte du soja des huiles
végétales de tournesol de polza entre
autres et puis si on regarde la
répartition des exportations
ukrainiennes elles sont composées pour
un cinquième environ de céréales
viennent ensuite les exportations de fer
et d'acier plus de 17 et demi pour cent
puis les huiles et les graisses
végétales juste en dessous de 10% du
total des exportations ukrainiennes on
comprend mieux pourquoi l annonce du
président russe d'une opération
militaire en ukraine fait trembler les
marchés des céréales et des matières
premières agricoles qui risquent de voir
leur prix grimper encore plus au cours
des prochains jours des prochaines
semaines avec des conséquences évidentes
sur les perspectives d'inflation est
justement en parlant du commerce
international de l'ukraine le pays a
d'abord très tournée vers la russie a
développé ces dernières années ses
échanges commerciaux avec l'union
européenne qui est loin de son première
partie ce qui est devenu de loin et
partenaire commercial un seul en effet
depuis 2014 et l'annexion de la crimée
par à la russie l'ukraine a réduit ses
échanges commerciaux avec moscou dans le
même temps le pays s'est davantage
tourné vers l'union européenne avec la
mise en place d'un traité de
libre-échange qui a permis la
suppression des droits de douane sur de
nombreux produits et la majorité des
biens devraient être concernés d'ici
2023 conséquence l'union européenne est
désormais de loin le premier partenaire
commercial de l'ukraine le pays réalise
plus de 39% de ses échanges commerciaux
avec le bloc des 27 pays les échanges
avec la chine se sont aussi développées
ces dernières années vous voyez 14,9
pour cent de l'ensemble des échanges
commerciaux c'est plus du double des
échanges réalisés avec la russie en 2020
porte aux échanges commerciaux avec les
états unis il reste limitée à 3,1 pour
cent du total des importations et des
exportations
et déjà avant cette annonce l'économie
ukrainienne commencé à subir de plein
fouet les conséquences de l'intervention
russe oui et des conséquences
importantes d'abord sur le secteur du
transport l'une après l'autre de
nombreuses compagnies aériennes ont
suspendu leurs vols vers l'ukraine à
cause des craintes pour la sécurité des
passagers mais aussi parce que les
compagnies d'assurance ne vous plus les
couvrir les transporteurs maritimes
craignent aussi d'être confronté à un
problème similaire et de devoir réduire
leurs activités faute d'assurances et à
cause des conditions de navigation
incertaine en mer noire et puis le
secteur de la restauration aussi a été
touchée avec des restaurants qui n'osent
pas s'approvisionner en avance au delà
de quelques jours et puis l'incertitude
actuelle elle pèse aussi beaucoup sur le
climat des affaires et les
investissements étrangers dans le pays
le président ukrainien évoque même des
sorties de capitaux est estimé selon lui
à près de 12 milliards et demi de
dollars qui auraient donc été retirés
des comptes bancaires du pays à la fin
janvier d'ailleurs pour éviter ces
fuites de capitaux il a annoncé des
limites un plafond sur les retraits
bancaires juste à l'instant dans ce
contexte la monnaie ukrainienne a aussi
perdu 8% de sa valeur depuis le début de
l'année et au delà de ces effets de
court terme est bien le conflit avec la
russie pèse aussi depuis des années sur
la croissance ukrainienne
economics and business research estime
ce coût à 280 milliards de dollars de
pib perdus entre 2014 et 2020 et dans ce
contexte économique difficile l'ukraine
avait déjà reçu des promesses d'aidé
financière de la part des occidentaux en
effet des aides venant à la fois des
pays et d'institutions financières
internationales d'abord les etats-unis
qui ont promis un milliard de dollars de
garanties de crédit le royaume uni de
son côté est disposé à offrir des
garanties à hauteur de 500 millions de
dollars puis au sein de l'union
européenne le parlement européen a donné
son feu vert pour des près d'un milliard
trois cents millions de dollars pour
couvrir les besoins de financement du
pays cette année enfin du côté des
organisations financières
internationales la banque mondiale devra
se prononcer et fin mars sur le
versement d'une aide de près de 350
millions de dollars sous la forme de
prêts à court et long terme et le fonds
monétaire international donc
organisé à partir depuis hier une
mission virtuelle dans le pays pour
décider d'une nouvelle tranche des de
son programme verser une nouvelle
tranche d'être de son programme 700
millions de dollars donc sont en jeu sur
un programme d'un montant total de 5
milliards de dollars merci beaucoup pour
tout c